Good morning class. Today we do the
theory
of
everything.
So very quickly
I will explain to you what science tells
us about where we came from, who we are,
and where we're going.
So
as you may know it all started with a
big bang.
Okay?
The big bang.
So in the beginning there was a massive
ball of energy. And then it exploded.
Okay?
And because of this explosion
it would
create stars and planets and black holes
and solar systems.
And that's how the universe was created
through the big bang.
Then we had the Earth.
And on Earth life evolved starting with
um plants and sea life and then we had
um lizards, mammals, and then we got to
humans.
Okay? So evolution.
The thing about evolution that's very
important to understand is that it's all
about mu- mutation.
So the genes will randomly mutate.
And then those genes that are best
adapted to the environment will survive.
Okay? And this is the idea of the
survival of the fittest introduced to us
by
Charles
Darwin.
Okay? And that's how we came to dominate
the planet because we are the fittest
because we're able to work together
because we have language which allows us
to
store knowledge and pass it on to future
generations, to accumulate new
technology. Okay? So that's the theory
of evolution.
Now we get to the human mind.
Right? The human mind is unique in the
universe.
Um it allows us to communicate with each
other. It allows us to imagine things.
It It allows us to be creative.
And so neuroscience
teaches us that our brains what we Our
brains do is we filter experiences
into memories.
Now if you take in psychology you will
know that there's long-term memory and
short-term memory. Short-term memory is
just what you have today. Long-term
memory is what stays in you. Okay? So
what the brain does is that
it differentiates between short-term and
long-term. And then this long-term
is stored into a database of memories.
And it's divided according to your
emotions.
Okay? Happy
sad, angry, scared. Okay? So there's a
rainbow of emotions and all your
memories are stored according to the
different emotions inside your brain,
the database of your brain. And from
this you're able to create an identity.
Identity is basically an understanding
of who you are, your place in the world,
and how you should best navigate
the world.
Okay?
So the idea of identity. Now what you
also learn in psychology is it is
possible for you to create many
different identities.
So in a school you're a student, at home
you're a child, at work you're an
employee, okay? And all these identities
put together is called a worldview.
And you can understand this as your
personality.
Okay?
All right. So this is all that science
knows. I mean this is pretty simple, but
this is what science tells us about
where we came from, who we are, where
we're going. Now there are three
distinct characteristics about the
scientific worldview that's very
important for us to
understand. Okay?
The first is that this is all random.
Okay? This is really important. Because
before we understood this as
design. Okay? Before we believed that
there was a God. Now we believe there's
no God. All this is just random. That's
the first thing I need you guys to
remember.
Second thing I need you guys to remember
is that it's all material material.
Before we understood the universe as
spirit, mainly spirit, but now we
understand it as mainly material, things
that we can see and touch. We cannot see
it, we cannot touch it, we cannot
measure it, it does not exist.
The third characteristic is that it is
emergent.
Emergent, which is basically means
bottom-up.
You have like these particles, they
become atoms, then the atoms become
matter, they become
stuff, and then we become chairs or
people. Okay? This is all emergent.
And so these are the three major
principles of our worldview today.
And you should have learned most of this
in
science class.
Now
there's a problem with all these
theories.
All right. So I'm going to go over them
one by one.
And I want to I want to make sure you
follow along. Okay? Because what I will
do now is I will show you the problems,
the deficiencies,
the flaws in all these theories.
Okay.
So let's start with the
big bang.
Now
if it is true
that
the universe started off with a big bang
and it just expands slowly
then
it should it should expand linearly.
Okay?
But what we see is this. First of all,
the universe it expands weirdly. Okay?
It's more like this.
So as it expands different parts move
faster than other parts. That makes no
sense.
Also certain galaxies, okay? Galaxies
move faster than other galaxies.
This makes no sense either.
So
the way that astronomers have explained
away these
statistical problems is to introduce a
new concept called dark energy.
And dark energy is most of the universe.
It's It's like at least 80%. Some
scientists believe it is 90%. So most of
the universe is composed of dark energy.
And of course you're like, what is dark
energy? And the answer is
we don't know.
Now dark energy sounds like we don't see
it. That's how it is. It's we don't know
what it is.
And quite honestly it's cheating. Okay?
So let me give you an example. Let's
just say you take a math test and the
teacher asks you 987 plus 25 and your
answer is
20. Okay? That's obviously wrong, right?
So your teacher says
this is wrong. And then you say, oh, I
know how to fix this. Plus
dark energy.
Problem solved.
Okay? This is like literally what
cosmologists are doing with dark energy.
We don't know what it is.
But they say it must be there because
otherwise
we cannot explain
these statistical inconsistencies in our
measurements and modeling.
And then of course you're like, well,
why don't you just say that the big bang
theory is wrong? And they're like, well,
we could say that. The problem is we
don't have a better model. Well, in
fact, there is a better model. The
better model is there are different big
bangs.
Okay? So if you just assume that there
are different big bangs
well, this helps us better understand
what's going on better. But then the
question then then is wait a minute, if
there are multiple big bangs
why are there multiple big bangs?
Okay? So our current system of
understanding universe simply does not
work. And the problem is that it's
become a paradigm
a story
that is accepted by most scientists and
they refuse to budge on this issue.
Okay? But I'm telling you right now that
this system is clearly problematic and
it could be wrong. This is what's the
problem with
um the big bang. Now let's move on to
evolution.
Okay? Evolution.
Now
in theory, evolution does work, and it
works for most animals,
except when it comes to human beings.
Okay? Because that the the idea of
evolution is gradual progress.
But, we don't know how we went from the
ape, okay,
to the human.
We share with the ape,
other monkeys, 99.9%
of DNA.
But, we don't know why we're so
different from the ape.
Okay? That's the first problem. Second
problem is humans have been around for
for about 200,000
years, okay? That's a long, long time.
We only have maybe
50,000 years
of history.
So, where did the other 100,000 150,000
years go? We don't know.
Okay? So, this is also another huge
problem with the theory of evolution.
The third problem is
according to evolution, there should be
many different types of human beings.
But, in fact,
there's only one, Homo sapiens. Now,
what scientists will tell you is, "Well,
before there were different
species, the Neanderthal, the
Cro-Magnon, and then gradually Homo
sapiens took them over."
And that's And you can believe that, but
it's problematic because according to
evolution, there should be many, many
different types of humans, okay? Maybe
some with six fingers, some with three
eyes, like animals.
Okay? So,
the lack of diversity in the human
species, it's a it's it doesn't really
fit into the evolution model, okay?
All right. So, that's problem with
evolution.
The real problem
is with the human mind, okay?
So, let's go over some of the problems.
All right. So,
with neuroscience, what they teach you
is that what the worldview does, that's
very important, is that
it filters
memories. Okay? The reason why is every
day you're absorbing a lot of
experiences.
Your If your brain were to absorb all
the experiences, your brain would
explode. This is too much information to
process. Therefore, your worldview pro-
processes different experiences. It
differentiates between experiences that
are important and experiences that are
not important. Experiences that are
important, of course, goes into your
long-term memory.
The problem with this is
how about babies?
In theory, babies should not have a
worldview. They should not have a
personality. But, if that's the case,
then how do they process memories? How
do they know what memories to store,
what memories not to store?
Okay?
The other thing is that I have three
kids, and I can tell you that they're
all distinct personalities. It seems as
though they were born with a worldview.
And then the question then is, "Where
does this come from?"
Your eye color, your hair,
your height comes from your parents'
DNA, right? So, is your is your
personality from your parents' DNA?
Probably not, okay? Just ask yourself,
"Am I a composition of my parents'
personalities?" You're not. You're a
different person than your parents. So,
this is a huge problem with this model.
Where does the personality
come from? And why is it embedded in us
from the very first day?
Okay?
What's more problem- problematic is how
we think,
consciousness.
We do not have currently a model for how
we think.
In fact, if you study neuroscience, you
will find there are a lot of gaping
holes
in our understanding of the brain.
For example, we do not know where the
brain
stores memory.
That's very unusual because a memory is
a building block of everything. But, we
don't know in the brain where it is
stored.
Yeah?
>> Isn't that the hippocampus?
Excuse me? Isn't that the hippocampus
where
the memories are stored?
No. The hippocampus? Yeah. No, it's not.
We we don't know where where it's
stored. There's certain things
that we know where it's stored. For
example, we know where maybe language is
stored. We know where faces are stored,
okay? So, maybe the faces are stored in
the hippocampus.
But, we don't know where memory
is stored. Okay? So, what we say is the
entire brain stores memories. But,
that's another saying we don't know
where it's stored.
All right. So, the other thing is that
our current model of the brain,
it's like a city, okay? Think of the
brain as a city. And what makes the
brain work are the roads, or what we
call the synapses. When they hit each
other, it has it creates electricity.
And that's where we think
that
um how thought is generated.
Okay?
But, this is problematic because
um
we think a lot,
okay?
So, let me give you an example of this
to clarify.
Now, in science class, you're taught the
scientific method.
Okay? What's the scientific method?
Well, you do research,
you create a hypothesis
from the research,
and then you create an experiment to
test out the hypothesis. And then you
have data,
and then you make observations,
and then you refine the hypothesis,
okay?
And this is
what we believe a way to model the act
of thinking.
And you're taught this in every class,
even in in English class, right? You do
research, then you create an outline,
right? The outline has a thesis
with
three evidence, right? And then you
write it out, write a draft,
you edit it,
and you repeat the process.
Okay? This This is what you're taught in
school.
Okay.
I'm going to say something that shocked
that will shock you, okay?
This is what you you're taught in
school. This is what you believe works.
But, as someone who is much older than
you are, as someone who actually thinks
for a living, who teaches for a living,
who writes for a living, I'm going to
tell you
how you actually think is the complete
opposite.
Okay?
So, what happens is you actually
you actually
think or imagine
the story
or the idea to begin with, okay?
And then you start working backwards
to create the process.
You're taught in school it's a process
that creates the the idea. What I'm
telling you is that in reality, it's the
idea that creates the process.
Okay?
So, let me give you an example of this.
If you look at every major scientific
discovery, it all came to the person
in a dream
or when he was
or it sort of popped into that person's
head, okay? It's just think of a light
bulb light bulb popping up, okay? So, an
example is Albert Einstein.
Albert Einstein created his theory of
relativity not in a laboratory,
not by um doing research with other
scientists, but simply by sitting in a
patent office every day and just
daydreaming.
And then boom, the idea came to his
head. He's like, "Okay,
now I have this idea. Now, what I'm just
going to do is go back and look for the
evidence to support his idea."
Yes? And a hypothesis is like an idea.
Okay.
Um is a hypothesis the idea?
Okay. No, the hypothesis is the
assumption.
Okay? What Okay, what what what I'm
trying to tell you tell you is this.
What I'm trying to tell you is the idea
or the final product comes first.
Then you go backwards,
okay?
And you create the draft. Then you
create the outline. Then you do the
research.
Okay?
Now, I know this sounds weird, but let
me give you a few more examples.
James Watson came up with the double
helix model of DNA.
How he did this was he spent years and
years working to figure out how DNA
worked. And then boom, one day he had a
dream of a staircase, a double
staircase. And he's like, "Maybe that's
the
model I need to use." And then he
started to do more research and
discovered, "Hey, this works."
Okay? But but the question then is, how
that get into his head?
Okay? Let me give you another example.
Um I write books.
And I've written three novels.
Um and you won't believe this, okay? But
but my wife is here and and like she
knows how I work.
You would think that when you write a
book, you would spend every day at at
the desk and
um
read books, take notes, and then
transform it into a book, right?
I don't do that.
What I do is I lie in bed
and I might play some video games or
might read a book, okay? I get up, I
walk to the park,
and I come back
and I've all these ideas.
And I write down all these ideas over 1
hour, 2 hours on the computer, okay? And
then I'm exhausted. I've run out of
ideas.
And I'm like, okay, tomorrow, what am I
going to do if I have no ideas? I can't
write anymore. But what happens is the
next day I get up and I have new ideas.
And I write it back and I I write it
down again, okay? So it's not like I am
generating these ideas, it's more like
I'm receiving these ideas.
If you watch me actually watch me work,
it is almost impossible
to think that I actually do any work cuz
I'm always like lying around or walking
around or daydreaming, okay?
My wife tells me that when I write
or when I work, it's like I'm possessed.
I'm possessed by something, okay?
Meaning like I actually I don't see
anything
and I really don't know what other
people are doing cuz I don't care.
I don't care because I'm focused on my
work. Okay?
Also, I'll give you another example, the
way I teach.
Now, when you see me teach, you think,
"Oh, you must have a script. You must
have outlined the
class." I don't do that.
I have a conception, I have a framework
in my head.
I come to class and I teach. How do I
teach? I watch your observations,
I watch your facial expressions,
and based on your responses, I then
start to flesh out
the framework.
And how how and and and and how do I do
that? Because I'm always accessing a
higher force and I'm receiving this
information that I can then
articulate it to you in class.
And that's why if you have been with me
for a long long time,
10 years, you will know I've never
taught the same class ever.
You can go on YouTube and watch all my
videos. I teach the this class different
each time because each time what I'm
doing is I'm channeling a higher force
and bringing it to you.
But it is a conversation, it's a
dialogue.
It's no different from reading a book or
seeing a great painting, okay? Each
experience is unique because when you
because a painting or the book, it's
almost like a platform for you to
experience the divine or higher power.
Okay? When you read a great book, that's
literally what you feel. You feel as
though you are in conversation with the
universe. And this book is really a
portal into
the universe.
Okay? If you read a good great great
book, I'm not sure if if you've had if
you've had uh
read a good great book, okay?
So, if you want to really be creative,
you have to trust the universe.
If you we don't we don't want to destroy
your creativity, you follow this system.
Okay? So, what I'm telling you and I I
know this this is going to be weird, but
school,
it destroys your creativity because it
teaches you a process that does not
work. No scientist in the history of
humanity has ever come up with a great
idea using the scientific method.
I guarantee you. They've all came up
with a great idea through their
imagination, through their intuition, by
channeling the divine. Okay? That's
every single scientist including um
Einstein, Newton,
uh yes?
Wait wait sorry sorry can you speak a
little
Okay, so
I agree with what you're saying, but I
personally I I I think scientific method
is more like how
people how these inspirational ideas are
being presented to others.
>> Oh, yes. Yeah, good point. Exactly.
That's that's exactly right, okay? So, I
use scientific method in order to
convince other people that I'm correct.
You're absolutely correct. Because I if
I told people, "Oh, I had a dream."
Well, like it's not convincing, okay?
So, the scientific method, it's a way
for for us to communicate and spread
ideas. You're absolutely you're
absolutely correct. Okay? But as I say,
you will never ever have a great
discovery by following scientific
method. You have to have an inspiration.
And then you use scientific method to
explain your inspiration to other
people.
Okay?
Yeah?
And another thing, sorry. And another
thing is that I I think how people
absorb ideas or
uh
like like how how how you wrote a book
is by based on your
at least some some of the points are
based on your experience because let's
just say a person has born and he never
like he has no knowledge and he has no
experiencing on
uh any things. And I don't see the
possibility for him to just observe this
energy out of nothing. Okay, you're
exactly correct. Yes. And I'll explain
this as we move on, okay?
All right, but I want to show you
there's lots of issues with um how
the scientific method is taught in
school, okay? So, but but but are you
guys clear? All right, but but but but
that's a good point. Let me continue.
All right.
So, let me continue.
We have
so much evidence
that we communicate with a higher power
all the time. All right, so so let's go
over some of the evidence, okay? The
first piece of evidence is
near-death experiences.
NDEs.
Near-death experiences
are
um when you almost die, okay? Or you're
dead for like 10 seconds or 10 minutes,
who knows.
But there are thousands, tens of
thousands of these testimonies on
YouTube and they all say the same thing.
When they die, they see a tunnel and at
the tunnel, there's a light that draws
them.
Okay? They go and then suddenly they are
high up.
And they feel tremendous love, peace,
forgiveness, compassion. It's all good.
And then they submit to a life review.
They have a chance to reflect on their
entire life. They can see all the pain
they caused. They can see all the good
they've done in the world.
And
then they're asked by a higher force and
it's it's like God or an angel, but like
there are different interpretations,
okay?
Do you want to go back? They always
says, "Yes, I need to go back." Why?
Because I need to tell people about my
experience. They come back extremely
changed people. And again, these are
people who don't know each other
and maybe before they were atheists
or just scientists, but once they have
these experiences, it changes them
forever, okay? So, near-death
experiences, we have problems explaining
why this is the case. Second is the is
the idea of psychedelics.
Okay.
Okay, psychedelics. So, throughout human
history,
every culture has had it has used
psychedelics because psychedelics were a
way for shamans or priests to access the
divine.
And
what's really interesting is
when you use a certain type of
psychedelic, you end up seeing the same
images
regardless of who you are.
Okay? And that's why
civilizations
throughout human history,
what's amazing is if you go back to the
ancient past and you look at different
civilizations in different parts of the
world, they have very similar statues
and paintings, okay? So, what's a very
common motive
is the idea of the cosmic serpent. For
whatever reason, every early
civilization has worshipped a serpent or
serpent the serpent is a very important
part of their culture. And it's possible
that when they're on psychedelics
and they're meditating, they see a
serpent talking to them and they see
that as the serpent of life, okay? And
also, what's really interesting is the
serpent, it's almost it looks like the
DNA.
Right? Okay? So, that's really really
interesting.
Okay?
Um meditation.
When people meditate,
when you go up to a higher
um
dimension, you have you end up you end
up having the same experience as
psychedelics and near-death experiences.
Also,
great books.
I myself have never done psychedelics.
I obviously can't go back in the past
and study these civilizations. I never
had a near death near-death experiences,
but I've read Dante. I've read Milton.
I've read Homer. I've studied them very
very closely. And it what's amazing to
me is they say the same things.
When Dante in his Divine Comedy, when he
describes the universe, when he
describes God, when he describes the
heavens, it's almost as though he's
describing a near-death experience. You
know, we have actually no evidence that
Dante himself had a near-death
experiences.
Okay?
So, this is shocking.
Okay? So, there's a lot of evidence that
there's a higher
force beyond us.
So, the spirit world does exist.
Again, I can't prove it exists, but a
lot There's a lot of evidence to suggest
it does exist. Okay? So, now the
question then is
if our current model of reality doesn't
really work,
what is
another possibility? Okay? And in this
class, I'm not trying to tell you what
is true, but I'm just trying to present
you new possibilities. So, what I'm
going to do now is I will present to you
a new possibility of how of how reality
is structured, okay? All right. So, to
begin, let's talk about Kant.
Immanuel Kant was the greatest
philosopher whoever lived, the most
influential philosopher whoever lived,
because he introduced
us the idea that we are not observers
of reality, we are participants in
reality.
All right? So, let me explain what he
means.
For Kant, there's a noumenon. The
noumenon just means reality that is
outside of us, the things in themselves.
What he tells us is we can never know
know the noumenon. We can never know
this reality. Why? Because whenever we
see reality, we filter it using time and
space.
Okay? So, time and space do not exist
outside of us. They are parts of us. We
use time and space in order to interpret
reality in a way that allows us to make
sense of it, okay? So, the noumenon
through time and space becomes the
phenomena.
And that's all we see, the phenomena,
the things that are to me, not the
noumenon, the things in themselves.
Okay? And so, we imagine reality. We
hallucinate reality.
Okay? But, of course, this creates three
problems. Okay, the first problem is
uh what is the noumenon?
The second problem is
why do we have these filters, time and
space? The third problem is
how do how can we guarantee that what I
see is the same as what you see?
Because if reality is a subjective
experience,
then in theory everyone should see it
differently.
But, we all see it the same, okay?
So, why is that? So, these are the three
problems. And so, what happens is that
Hegel comes along, okay? Hegel, another
German philosopher, and he explains the
idea of the Geist. So, his thing is that
the noumenon, it's really a spirit
world. It's the Geist.
And when you do this, it solves all
three problems, okay? The noumenon you
can never access because it's beyond us.
It's the Geist that gives us time and
space.
And as a result, because it's all coming
from one source, we see the world in the
same way.
Okay?
All right. So,
this sounds complicated, but you but but
let me now use quantum mechanics to
explain what this means, okay? Let's
Let's talk about quantum mechanics.
Okay. So, in science class, you're
taught the Neil
Bohr
model of the atom. Okay? It's a simple
model. You have the nucleus,
and then around the nucleus you have
these electrons that orbit
the nucleus. Okay, you're taught this in
physics class.
Um if you are in a more advanced
physics, you were taught that it's
actually an electron cloud.
Why? Because we never know for sure
where electrons are. So, we can only
know the probability of where they are
in orbit, okay? So, it's called an
electron cloud. And this is what you're
taught in school. When you go to
university, you're you will be taught
this is completely and utterly wrong.
Why? Because
this assumes
that these atoms are matter. They're
solid. But, in reality, if you go deep
enough, you will find that
they are actually just vibrations, what
we call quantum fields.
And they are just vibrations. And what
the electron really is is an
intersection
of these quantum fields.
Also,
these quantum fields can always exist in
two states. The first is as a wave, the
second is as a particle.
Okay?
And we can only know if it's a wave or a
particle by observing it.
And this is what's called a wave
function collapse.
In other words,
all of nature is vibrational. It's
energy. And it's only when we observe
it, when we interact with it, that it
becomes something solid that we can see
and measure and touch.
Okay? It's called a wave function
collapse.
Okay?
So,
this is complicated. So, a physicist
named Erwin Schrödinger, he creates a
thought experiment called Schrödinger's
cat, okay? You may have heard of it,
Schrödinger's cat.
And so, imagine a box, and inside is a
cat.
And then the cat in inside the box is
also some caustic chemicals
that may or may not break. If it breaks,
the cat dies. If it doesn't break, the
cat the cat's still alive.
And what Schrödinger teaches us is that
when the box is unopened, we can never
know the state of the cat. It's only
when we open it can we know it's dead or
alive. But, before then, it's both dead
and alive.
Okay? That's simple to understand. But,
then another physicist introduces a new
concept called the friend experiment or
Wigner's friend.
And this is more complicated because he
says, "Okay,
if you are the experimenter and you open
the box, you now know the state of the
cat.
But,
what if you're a friend?
Okay?
You're You don't see the box.
You're outside of the laboratory.
When the experimenter opens the box,
does the wave function collapse?
And the answer is it does not.
Okay? It does not. And what this is
telling us
is there is no objective reality
that exists outside of you.
When the experimenter opens the box, the
wave function collapses for him, but it
does not collapse for the observer and
for anyone else.
We have to open the box ourselves in
order to see if the cat is alive or
dead.
Okay?
But, what if
this person tells us the answer is it
still doesn't collapse.
We have to participate in the reality
ourselves. And what this is saying,
okay, this is hard to understand, is
that
everyone lives in his or her own
reality.
Everyone has a unique universe onto
himself or herself.
And that's what quantum mechanics
teaches us.
Okay? All right.
So, now let's try to, based on all this,
okay, Kant and quantum mechanics,
create a theory of reality.
Okay? So, what's important to understand
is that
all everything are just vibrations.
Okay? That's all it is. It's vibrations.
Yeah?
I thought like quantum uh mechanics can
only be applied on quantum, whereas we
are a
a a
a macro creature. It is not Yeah, that
is correct. But, the quantum mechanics
is the is the basis of reality.
Right? Okay? So, we are So, everything
are just vibrations.
Now, what happens is that
what we need to understand is that if
it's vibrations, if it's energy, it's
also information.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right.
So, what our brains do is
our brains are not independent. Our
brains connect to the universe, okay?
So, as the universe is vibrating, we're
receiving information.
And then through our experiences,
okay? This vibration allows us to turn
it into memories.
You understand?
We're taking this
um
vibrational information, we're taking
our experiences, we're combining to
memories.
Now, this is really important.
The memories now go back to the
vibrational force.
So, our memories are connecting to the
universe, and they're being stored in
the universe. They're being imprinted in
the universe. It's an imprint.
And this And this of course is no
different from the internet, right?
On the computer, whatever you write is
being stored on the internet.
So, whatever you do is going to change
the internet.
And you receive information from the
internet, okay? So, you're participating
in the internet and you're part of the
internet.
And the same thing is happening here.
Okay? So, everything's vibrational. If
it's vibrational, it's information. We
We turn We take the information and we
combine it with experiences and turn it
into memories. The memories then go back
to the universe. And so, it's as as it's
as though we can implant ourselves into
the universe.
Okay?
Now, this is hard to understand.
So, what we've done
is every single culture has turned this
knowledge into a story
that is easy for people to understand.
Okay? So, I'm going to tell you the
story. And this story, this framework,
I'm actually using Dante, okay?
All right.
Dante. What What does Dante tell us
about the universe? Okay, there's the
monad,
the one, God, who knows, okay?
But it's the source of everything.
And so, what he does is he vibrates.
He emanates. He thinks. He breathes.
And this creates
vibrational force, right? And this
vibrational force creates new forces
called dyads.
Dyads are pairs.
And when the pairs come together and
vibrate, they create new things, okay?
So, this is how creation happens.
Through vibration, through the
combination of different um forces,
okay?
Now, what's important to understand is
that as the dimensions go lower, the
frequency decreases. So, at high, it's
really fast, right? It's like
Okay? When it goes low, it becomes low
frequency. Oh. Okay?
And eventually, you get a point where
matter
can be created. Okay? So, this is
spirit.
This is matter. And this is the world
that we live in.
Okay?
So, now the question then is why is the
universe set up in this way?
It has to do with the fact that the
universe, the monad, strives for
newness,
for imagination, for freshness.
The problem, though, is that in the
spirit world, everything is perfect.
Everything is eternal. Everything is
immutable. And so, by definition,
you can feel no pain.
You cannot suffer. You cannot make any
mistakes. Therefore, you cannot you
cannot have any new experiences.
Therefore, you cannot you cannot have
have any imagination.
So, we humans exist in order to solve
this problem. We humans are corporal,
which is what all this means is we have
bodies, okay?
If you have bodies, you go you get old.
You bleed. You get hurt. You fall down.
Okay? You feel
um anger. You feel hate.
But this allows us to have an
imagination.
And the imagination allows the universe
to grow,
to expand,
to vibrate.
Okay? That's our function. To have
experiences that are new, which expands
the consciousness of the universe. The
universe itself is consciousness.
All right.
So,
for this system to work, there have to
be some guiding principles to this
universe. The first and most important
principle is
the principle of free will.
Without free will, this system cannot
work.
If If you are If If you do what you're
supposed to do,
you can't have imagination, okay? So,
you have to disobey. You have to make
your own choices. You have to make your
own mistakes.
And this is what allows the universe to
imagine.
Okay? But the problem then is, if you
have free will, how do you know you're
doing good? How do you know you're doing
evil? And the answer is the idea of
love.
Okay? So, the monad is the totality of
We are a part of the monad.
Okay? We're part of the monad. And so,
there's a spark of the monad in us
called love.
And so, when we do good, we feel good
because the love, the spark, is growing
in us.
And
it's almost like a magnet, okay?
We want to return to the monad.
And so, we do good because it makes us
feel good and allows us to return to the
monad.
But sometimes,
because we live in a world of free will,
we make mistakes.
Okay? We might hurt someone. We might We
might be We might traumatize someone. In
which case, we feel anger. And then this
becomes
a vicious cycle, okay?
So, now there's another system set up to
ensure
we don't get trapped by our hate. And
this system is called death.
Okay?
In this system, death is release.
It prevents us from forever making
mistakes. Because you could have a
terrible life, right? But it's okay
because then you go die, you go back you
go back into the universe, and now you
can observe everything that you did,
okay? You can see all the pain you've
caused. You can see all the good that
you've done.
And so, you become wiser.
Then you come back and you live another
life. And again, you can make the same
mistakes over and over, but you can also
improve, okay?
Now,
the other thing to remember about the
system is that
it's our choice whether to create love
or hate. Now, love
goes back to the monad.
But what happens when you create hate?
Well, you need to store it somewhere, so
it goes into lower dimensions, okay?
Hate.
All right. So, we create new dimensions
through hate, through anger, through
fear, through bad emotions that cannot
return to the spirit world because the
spirit world is perfect.
And so, this is called hell.
And this is called heaven.
Okay? And this is how the universe is
set up.
Okay? So, I
I'm just taking the literal reality and
turning it into the metaphorical
reality, which becomes the basis of all
early religions.
Okay? So,
there are different metaphors that we
can use to understand
uh
this system. But let's look at let's
look at look at
um one from Hinduism and one from Dante,
okay?
So, in Hinduism, there's a metaphor
that's very powerful.
And the metaphor is that
in the
house of
the god Indra. Indra is one of the most
powerful gods of India.
There's all these pearls
that float, okay? What do What do pearls
do? They reflect other pearls.
And what happens is this. Because
there's a spark in us, if one of our
sparks grows bright, all the other
pearls grow bright as well.
Okay? So, literally, because
God is inside of you, because there's a
spark inside of you, because you're
capable of love, when you do love,
you're capable of changing the entire
universe.
Because your love expands outward, and
your love reflects in other people as
well.
Okay? So, Dante uses the idea of
mirrors.
There's a candle, there's a flame, and
we're all mirrors
that reflect
the candle.
Okay? God's God's the candle. We're just
the mirrors.
But every one of us,
no matter how far we are from God,
we
um the his flame burns in us.
Okay?
So, you could be far away,
and you could feel as though God has
forgotten you, but there's still the
flame inside you.
Okay? So, for Dante and for our early
civilizations,
God is love
forever, okay? Eternal love. But God is
also eternal compassion, eternal
forgiveness. God will never forgive you.
Oh, sorry. God will never forget you,
okay? He will always forgive you.
But you have to believe in God to return
to God. You have to live a life of
righteousness, of love, of compassion,
of imagination, if you want to return to
God.
Okay?
So, that's how the universe is set up.
We are here. Our divine mission is to
expand the consciousness of the
universe. We do that by embracing love
and by imagining the world to be a
better place.
Okay?
All right.
So, now let's go back and ask yourselves
this question.
If
every single early religion, whether
it's a dualism or Hinduism,
or the Egyptians, or the Native
Americans, if every early religion all
believed this and all they all knew
this,
how did we come to forget or deny this
with a material reality? Okay? Remember,
the Big Bang, evolution, neuroscience,
it's to teach us that
there's no God. There's no purpose. It's
all just random. It's all just material.
So, how do we get this to this point?
Okay.
The answer is very simple and we'll be
discussing this throughout class
throughout the rest of the semester,
okay?
The problem is that you have heaven,
you have earth,
and you have hell.
Okay?
The heaven is spiritual.
It's consciousness.
Hell, it's mechanical. It's machines.
Okay? We're stuck in between. It's
always our choice whether to choose
heaven or hell because of
free will.
Okay? And for most of human history, we
have chosen
um heaven.
But eventually, you have people who
chose hell.
And when you choose hell, you have
access to technology,
right?
And this technology allows you to
conquer and control other people.
Okay? But once you control and you
conquer and control the people, you have
to get them to obey you.
If you are enlightened, if you know the
truth, you know that none of this
matters. We're all We're all going to go
We're all going to die. So, why should I
listen to you?
So, in order for me to control you, I
need you to fear death.
Okay?
I need you to forget God,
and I need you to fear death.
When you die, death is the worst thing
that can happen to you.
Be And be be Because remember, before
people understood, death was just a part
of the journey. It was a release. It was
an opportunity to reset yourself and
come back. Now, death is the worst
thing that could ever happen to you.
Okay? So, how do you forget God and how
do you
uh get people to fear death? You use
science,
right?
And you create theories like the Big
Bang, like evolution, like neuroscience
to forget to make people forget the
divinity inside
you.
Right?
So, that's what science
is for.
But unfortunately,
for these people, that's not enough.
Because eventually, we're all die,
right?
So, the only way around this is by
creating a new technology called
transhumanism.
Okay?
You may have heard of transhumanism.
Again, don't worry about the concept
now. We'll We'll discuss this later on
the semester. But transhumanism is to
surpass humanity,
which basically means to defeat death.
To upload you, your brain, to the
internet so you're here forever.
Okay?
To trap you here forever.
And so, now the question then is
um why are they doing this?
Why people in power doing this?
Okay. So, um
As we discussed in this class,
throughout human history, it's usually
secret societies that have the power.
Okay?
Why? Okay. Well,
we last class we discussed the idea of
bureaucracy, right? Mass bureaucracy.
And we discussed how in a mass
bureaucracy, bureaucrats don't really
want to do anything. They're lazy.
Well, guess what? If you're part of a
secret society and you're able to
coordinate secretly together, you can
control the bureaucracy cuz you're the
only people doing stuff.
Okay?
But then the question then But the
problem is bureaucracies do not like
secrets,
secret societies. So, you have to
maintain your secrecy. And how And how
do you do that?
You do that through transgression.
If you guys are doing bad things
together, okay? Now you have blackmail
on each other.
And therefore, you're committed
to keeping each other's secrets. If one
of you falls down, everyone falls down
together, okay? So, now you're committed
to
um maintain the secrets.
But the problem is this. The problem is
okay, it's conspiracy, but the moment
you're found out, they'll come and
arrest you.
So, how do you work together without
actually meeting each other? And the
answer is
religion.
Okay? Or the word we use is eschatology.
Religion is just a script, an
understanding of the world that allows
you to coordinate secretly.
Okay? Does Does all this make sense?
Okay. So, now these these secret
societies, they are embedded in mass
bureaucracy and they're manipulating the
bureaucracy and they're working together
uh to commit transgression. They have
their own secret religion.
Okay? When you combine these three
together, what happens is that they're
now forced to invert
this understanding, inversion.
Why?
Because they know that they're doing
evil in this world. So, when they go and
meet God, God's going to punish them,
right?
So, the way to get around this is well,
I will just cele I will just worship
someone who is superior to God, who is
Satan, okay?
Okay.
So, what they're going to do is they're
going to invert this, okay? By serving
Satan,
they can now justify all their
transgressions, right? As a way to
empower Satan.
Also, there's a fundamental weakness in
this system, okay?
So, let's go over the three main
characteristics of the system. The first
is unity.
Okay?
So, this entire system is complete and
unified. Second is symmetry.
Symmetry or polarity.
And what this means is that if there's
good, there must be evil. If there's
ugliness, there must be beauty. Why?
Because you cannot have one without
without the other, okay?
One thing is meaningless without without
the other. That's why you have God, you
must have Satan, okay?
And the third principle is
as above,
so below.
And what this means
is that everything is a reflection of
each other.
So, you can never defeat God,
but what you can do is corrupt human
beings to worship Satan so that Satan
becomes everything.
Okay?
All right.
I I guess you're following along.
Okay? So, what you're trying to do is
you're trying to invert this world. And
how do you invert this world? What you
do is you know that hell is material,
and you know that heaven is spiritual,
right?
What you do is you brainwash people to
worship the material world and abandon
the spiritual world. You make money,
power, technology, science the greatest
things in the world.
Okay? You get rid of God. You get a
religion. You get rid of compassion. You
get rid of You get rid of love.
And that's how you control the
world. So, in other words,
what is happening today is a war between
heaven and hell.
The people in charge, the secret
societies, they are interested They must
make heaven in make hell into heaven and
heaven into hell. They must invert the
world in order to maintain their power.
Okay? And that's what we'll be focusing
on for the rest of the semester, this
war between heaven and hell.
How it came about, who are the major
players, and what will happen.
Yeah?
So, I'm a bit confused about the part
where
um so, the secret society
are manipulating their power beyond the
rest of the people. And so, they are
devoting themselves into the power of
Satan, right? But my question is, so
the the
God and Satan, they don't interview they
don't interfere to our world. And so,
these are all just decisions made by the
secret society itself.
>> Yep.
Okay, so
if
Well, in that case, if say say Satan now
goes beyond or has the power that goes
be beyond God, then God wouldn't do
anything to like rebuke or something?
Yeah, okay. Great great great, okay. So,
um first thing to remember
is that because of the principle of free
will, God and Satan cannot interfere in
this world.
Okay?
Secondly, you have to remember that
there are different secret societies.
There are a thousand different secret
societies, okay?
The secret societies that are able to
use all three principles to accumulate
power on the on the most successful.
Okay?
So, that's why they're promoting Satan.
Um then, the third question then is
um
why doesn't God do it do anything about
this?
Okay?
And the answer is
because if you think about it,
in only a time of complete darkness,
only when Satan rules,
can humans fully shine.
Right? Does that make sense?
So, God has trust in us. God has faith
in us. God loves us completely. God
believes that someone will stand up and
do the right thing.
And when that person does the right
thing, the universe will shine.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Right? So, only in a time of darkness
can the light truly shine.
And remember, when someone shines that
light, that light is reflected in
everyone else. So, everyone's light
shines as well.
Okay?
So, that's the idea here.
You can choose to shine
if you want.
But only if the world becomes really
evil and dark and sinful, can you have
this option.
Okay? Yeah, back back back there.
Like is there a really a God or a Satan
but
uh like there's a
God for all of the and
a God for all of the bad things or it's
just two two worlds which is one
positive, one negative? Okay, that's
that's a really good question, okay? So,
what all this is saying is this, okay?
In reality, literally, everything is
vibrations. All right? How these
vibrations work, right? Nobody knows,
but it's all just vibrational.
But what we know is we are participants
in the universe. So, if we all believe
God exists, guess what? God exists. We
all believe Satan exists, Satan exists.
Okay? That's why this war, it's not over
resources, it's over perception.
Do you understand? This is a war of
perception.
If I can get everyone in the world to
believe that God is dead and Satan is
the true God, I win.
Okay? And how do I do that? Well, I can
do that by shooting rockets up into
space, by putting man on the moon and on
Mars.
Okay? Why? Because now I destroyed the
concept of heaven. Before we've
understood that the moon, the Mars were
beyond us because they are heavenly,
they're spiritual.
But once I put man on the moon
and on Mars and go beyond, I've proven
heaven doesn't exist.
I've destroyed God.
I can also
fake an alien invasion
and pretend these aliens are Satan,
okay?
Okay? All of science, you you don't know
this, but all of science, it's not about
discovering reality, it's about
reinventing reality in a way that serves
power. That's what science really is.
Yeah?
So, is there people who like
they they don't believe in Satan or God,
they choose to let others believe in
them like
they're
making themselves into a God. Does it
work?
Like
because if you believe God
uh then God exists like like if if
everyone believes in it. So, if someone
make everyone believe in him or her
uh does does it work to make him into a
God or Satan some kind of? Okay, that's
that's a good question, and the answer
is no. Historically, what's happened is
that a charismatic leader has emerged to
say that I am God's representative.
Okay? Why? Because
um
we believe we're all equal.
Right? You're no different than I. What
makes you God? Well, the answer is
because I'm channeling God.
Okay? And historically, so like like
look look at the early the early
empires, the early kingdoms. What what
the king would say is that I'm descended
from God. God came down, had sex with my
mother, and now I'm born, okay? But that
person is not saying, you know, I am God
itself, but I am born of God.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay.
All right.
So, this is the basic framework for what
what what what we're working with the
rest of the semester. Okay? But
understand that what's happening today
is a war between heaven and hell.
If I can convince you that God is dead
and Satan is the true God. Like if I can
convince you that the material world is
real, the spiritual world is a lie. Like
if I can convince you
that
death is the worst thing to happen to
you and you should do all you can to
live,
then
hell has won, okay? But what's important
to understand is
this system is set up so that hell can
never win out. And the reason why is
the entire cosmos is interconnected.
So, if we do evil, if we feel pain, if
there's too much suffering in the world,
the Earth itself rebels.
Right? Because of vibrational energy.
And this leads to things like the great
flood,
which resets the world and lets humanity
renew itself.
Okay? So, there are all these different
fail-safe systems in there in here to
make sure
that um
hell can never triumph. And that's why
Elon Musk is wants us to go to Mars,
okay?
All right? But understand that if you
just use this concept of heaven and
hell, even though it's metaphorical,
even though God and Satan are just
projections of our imagination, they do
help us understand the world better.
Okay?
Okay. So, any questions? Any any more
questions be be before we we conclude
for today.
Great, okay. So, we'll continue this
tomorrow uh uh
um
Friday, yep. Okay.